- Say Happy Halloween to Loni Love.
(crowd cheering)
(mysterious music)
(mysterious music continues)
- I mean, what an entrance.
(laughing)
- I have one fang.
- I know you came in and I was like,
wait, there's only one fang.
You're like a sad vampire.
(laughing)
- I know.
I'm like a half vampire.
- Like a broken vampire
your eyes look amazing,
everything looks amazing.
- Thank you,
Give it up to your wonderful
hair, makeup and wardrobe.
They did this all for
me thank you so much.
(crowd cheering and applauding)
- They're so talented.
I love that movie, Quinn
of the Damned with Aaliyah.
- Oh yes.
I love it too.
And this is a tribute also
to the wonderful Aaliyah who played her.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so this is just wonderful.
Yeah, it really is.
- Yeah.
Oh, I loved it, I was
like, oh, she can act too.
I was like dang.
- Exactly.
- Do you enjoy dressing up in costume
- Kelly? I love dressing up.
This is, that's why, the only
reason why I came on show.
I said, Do I get to dress up?
Thank you, okay?
- I get excited when the people dress up
for Halloween on shows
when I go on them, I love doing it.
- This is, and this is so nice.
And, but when I was little, you know
the reason why I dressed up as an adult
because when I was little, you know
we didn't have a lot of money.
So my mom would always make me
the invisible woman, you know
(laughing)
- Tell them, can't nobody see
so she wouldn't have to buy a costume.
And I'm like, Ma, they can see me.
And she's like, no, you're invisible.
Tell them you're invisible.
But now Kelly, I am able to dress up
and now I'm dressing up, honey.
- I love it.
(crowd cheering)
I was the same way.
I didn't have a lot of
money growing up either.
And I think it's, I enjoy
so many more things now
with my kids too.
Cuz you, you, it's like we didn't get it.
So it's like I go all out for it.
- What are the kids gonna do?
Who are they gonna be?
- My, she lives Astrid
from the dragon movie.
the How to Train Your Dragon.
She love Astrid.
And I'm like, oh yes, she
picked a warrior, cool.
(laughing)
- And he's Aquaman, he's
in love with Aquaman.
- Oh yeah.
- He met Aquaman on here
once and so, on the show.
And he's like, since then, like in love.
- I love Aquaman too, but
for different reasons.
(crowd laughing)
- I gotta be honest with you.
I mean everybody in this,
nobody would kick Aquaman outta bed.
(crowd laughing)
- So you were Kim Kardashian
once, and I love this.
I wanna show everybody.
So wait, look at this,
look at these pictures.
(Loni Love laughing)
- Now this was Kim Kardashian at the Met.
So I wanted to be her.
Cause I said I wanna see if she
can see out of that costume.
I could not see.
I fell all into the set and everything.
So no, never play that.
- And I don't think I'd like,
it feels suffocating, right?
- It, it was a little
suffocating and you couldn't see.
So it was like, no, you know
I better do one like this
where I can be a queen.
I love being a queen.
- Yeah. I like, yeah.
And it's just an awesome outfit.
- With one fang.
- So wait, your new show tapes in Vegas.
Do you like living in Vegas?
- You know what, I like living in Vegas
but my assistant that
came with me cannot hang.
I have some pictures.
Let me show you, okay, cause I like to
when I go to Vegas, I
party, I do everything.
And Alex, you know, I had him with me,
but look at him, asleep.
- Oh my gosh
- Asleep.
Like take, talking about I'm taking a nap.
No, you asleep.
That's what you doing.
- Are you on the floor,
like actually gambling
- Yeah, I'm on the, I'm at the machine
and I look over he's asleep.
It's about four o'clock in the morning
but he's supposed to be up.
we all gotta meet?
- Did you say 4:00 AM?
- Yeah, don't you party in Vegas before?
- Are you out of your mind?
- Look there he go again.
I caught him the next day.
- Oh my
- I was like, dude how many
naps are you gonna take, okay?
- Well, oh my God.
Wait, you're, I'm not
able to hang like that.
I can't do that.
- Really?
- No, no.
- Rose I know you can hang
- Bit of jet lag.
If I come straight from New Zealand
and it'll feel like it's still lunchtime
I'll be there 4:00 AM I'll be good.
- Okay, okay.
See we can hang.
- I can never do that.
I will never hang.
I'm like a, I'm like a man.
When do they open?
That's when I wanna go eat.
Like when is the first meal being served?
- Yeah I do all of that.
I've been up for like three
weeks taping that show.
So I haven't slept.
- Oh, you don't want, I'm
not a nice person tired.
(laughing)
- Are you? I get very angry.
- Yeah. I can get angry but
I, you know, it's Vegas.
Vegas is just lovely.
And that's what I love about it.
And that's what I love
about this new show,
you know, Magic with the Stars is because
we were able to bring the stars to Vegas.
So I was able to hang out
with people like Donnie Osman.
- Yeah.
- And you know Johnny Weir
and it was a really cute family show.
Finally I got a family
show, other than yours.
(laughing)
- So wait, are you really afraid of rats?
- Yes, I am Kelly.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- But you live here?
- Yeah I live here.
Not New York.
- Do you know that there
are rats everywhere here?
- Not where I live.
- No people always talk about New York.
I had to get rid of like
hundreds in my backyard.
- Yes. Yes.
That's why I, that's the
only thing about New York
- These are fat rats.
Like real happy fat rats.
- Neither of you should
come to New Zealand
because New Zealand has bush rats
and they are like
- [Loni] what?
- They are the size of possums.
They are yeah, yeah.
- Oh no, no, no.
- Did you just cancel your tour?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just googled it in my heart.
I want to see what it looks like.
Oh my God.
Well we just thought you might like this-
No, I'm just kidding.
I didn't get a rat.
(laughing)
- Kelly don't do that.
- I saw you like fall, I
wouldn't do that to you.
I wouldn't do that to you,
but it would've been really funny.
Like a rat.
So wait, tell us a little
more about the show
and what it's like
working with Chris Angel.
- Well, Chris Angel, first of all,
everybody knows him, Legendary Magician.
And he has this wonderful
show at Planet Hollywood.
So he wanted to do a
competition with celebrities
to teach them magic.
And that's what he does.
So every episode you have
two different celebrities.
Like we had Cynth- Cynthony
Ooh, I can't talk with this one fang.
- I know it's just one fang.
- It is really hard talking with one.
I should have put the other fang in.
- It's like a snaggletooth.
- Anyway, it was two
celebrities doing magic
and it's every Saturday night.
So if you want a nice
family, you know thing
or you could sit around and watch magic.
And I don't know how they did it.
I was just happy to be
there cuz it was Vegas, so
- Yeah.
- You know, so thank you Chris Angel
- I love magic.
I, I'm like a child with it.
- You should do it for the next season.
- I think it's so impressive.
- You- do you think
because he teaches you
how to actually do it
like levitation, like the
real, you know, illusions.
Like he'll teach you how to levitate.
- See, I don't think I wanna know how,
I like to be, I like, I don't want,
I like the smoke and mirrors.
I don't wanna, I'm never
the person that's like
how did you really do that?
I just don't wanna know.
- So you like me?
So you'd be good as a judge.
So you need to come on as a guest judge.
- Yeah.
- Okay I already got you another job
- I don't wanna know the magic.
I don't want it to be spoiled.
Do you like magic?
- I love magic.
Yeah, I got to learn a magic trick once
I did on a show iZombie I got to
take on different characters
and I learned, I learned magic.
But it, there is the thing
of seeing behind the curtain a bit.
- Yeah.
- And you're like you know what?
I don't know, you can't go back from that.
- Yeah, yeah
- Yeah. It's like sixth
sense you already know.
- But I could never figure out
on the show how they were doing it.
So my thing as a judge
is to make sure that they
that I can't see that they
know how to do the illusion.
- Oh.
- And so that's what's
the entertaining part
about it is and it's a competition.
So we have people like
Flavor Flav going up
against an Olympian.
Who puts Flavor Flav against an Olympian?
Chris Angel does.
So, but that's why it's funny.
It's very entertaining.
- I love it was entertaining
watching you flee from that rat
- And fall.
- Did you injure yourself?
- No I didn't.
Cause Chris, he actually broke my fall.
- He knew it was coming.
- Yeah, he knew it was coming.
So that's how quick he is, you know?
Cause I was like wooh!
- I can't believe you opened it.
I was like, there's a rat in there.
I do think we have another
clip though, so watch this.
- Okay.
(intense music)
(screaming)
(crowd cheering)
- Chris Angel, ahhh!
- Where did he go?
- Yeah, yeah that's what he does.
- That just came out of his mouth?
- It was a scorpion in his mouth.
I didn't know cuz he, he tapped me.
- Was that that real?
- That was real, it was a real scorpion.
I thought it wasn't real until
it started actually walking.
I'm like, oh my goodness,
You know what I mean?
But that's what he does
throughout every episode.
He scares me.
How do I know something is not coming?
But I don't know, it's not coming.
It's too much, like this fang.
- You said too much like your one fang.